Speaker 1: This is just absolutely bonkers off
the wall, and it's really instructive in terms
of this idea of neutrality versus objectivity that
I've been talking about for years. At this point,
there is a Texas school official that has
been caught on an audio recording saying that
when teachers teach about the Holocaust,
there should also be opposing views.
What does that mean? It's not clear, but it sounds
pretty horrible. We have the audio first. Let me
just kind of get you up to speed with what this
is about. NPR reporting in one Texas district,
teachers were told to give opposing views of the
Holocaust, was a Texas school district, is again
the center of controversy after an administrator
reportedly instructed teachers to provide students
with opposing views of the Holocaust. Gina
Petty, the executive director of curriculum
and instruction for the Carroll Independent
School District in South Lake, Texas, is alleged
to have made the comments during last Friday's
meeting, according to NBC News, which has audio.
Let's just go right to the audio. Why
not? This is Gina Petty seeming to say
We need opposing views about the Holocaust.
Speaker 3: Make sure that if you have a book on
the Holocaust that you have one that has closing
and has others, how do you oppose the Holocaust?
Gina Petit did not respond to messages requesting
comment. I met with two concerned teachers.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Opposing views, guys opposing
views about the Holocaust. Now this is a
great opportunity to again say neutrality and
objectivity are two different things. There are
many individuals who profess neutrality when
neutrality is not nearly is not at all objective.
This is an issue on climate. This is an issue in
many areas of life and of discussion when we're
being objective. We're honestly seeking the truth,
whatever the truth turns out to be. No matter how
it might differ from my preconceived notions or
my biases going in, that's objectivity. We just
want the truth and we're not going to kneecap
a hamstring or limit our search for the truth
on the basis of our personal biases. Neutrality
is about a preconceived balance or agnosticism
between different positions where the truth
doesn't actually matter. Notice that neutrality
has nothing to do with truth. It's just this
idea where you're pre committing to being
indifferent or neutral or agnostic between
different conclusions or ideas. So when we
apply to the Holocaust, what's an opposing view
to the Holocaust like? We should include not only
real history books about the Holocaust, but also
like Nazi books about how Nazis felt about Jews
like we should. We should include the the
explanation of of Nazis as to why the Jews
deserved to die and students can determine was
the Holocaust good or was the Holocaust bad? Like,
Is that what we're talking about? Or we should
give a perspective as to why Hitler's goals were
noble, worthy and good goals. Like, what does
it actually mean to have an opposing view
of the Holocaust? We need the often misunderstood
perspective of the Nazis really needs to be
explained to kids. And of course, that's part of
what we teach most serious Holocaust studies. And
you know what's going on in Texas? I don't know,
but I would hope that it also is. The case would
include the views of the Nazis and why the Nazis
believed that the Jews had to die, as well as
those who have medical issues. And, you know,
we could go on and give the whole list. That's
part of the actual books that should be used. So
this is absolutely insane. As is mentioned in the
NPR article, Gina Petit is the name of the woman
allegedly on the recording there. She was asked
for comment and so far has not delivered any
comment. But the right question is the one that
you hear on the audio there. How do you oppose the
Holocaust? To which Patty responded. Believe me,
that's come up now. The school district head has
apologized and said there are not two sides of the
Holocaust. That's Layne Ledbetter, who put out a
statement saying As the superintendent of schools,
I express my sincere apology regarding the
online article and news story released today.
During the conversations with teachers during last
week's meeting. The comment? The comments made
were in no way to convey that the Holocaust was
anything less than a terrible event in history.
Additionally, we recognize there are not two sides
to the Holocaust as we continue to work through
implementation of HB three nine seven nine. We
also understand this bill does not require an
opposing view on historical facts. As a district,
we will work to add clarity to our expectation
for teachers, apologize for hurt or confusion
that this has caused. Now here is the thing
that they may be accurately saying. We're
not talking about two sides on the Holocaust,
but this House bill three nine seven nine. As
Karen Fitzgerald, the spokesperson, said for the
district, teachers across the state are put in a
precarious position by this bill. Our purpose is
to support our teachers in ensuring they will have
all of the professional development, resources and
materials needed. Our district has not and will
not mandate books be removed, nor will we mandate
that classroom libraries be unavailable. But it
still does put teachers in a precarious position
where they have to ultimately say there is no
controversy to teach here. Whereas in other
areas like on climate change, the entire point of
these bills is to claim there is a controversy and
that it must be that the science of climate has to
also be opposed by something else. And of course,
that's very different, different situation. So
while I guess they're apologizing for saying we
need opposing views on Holocaust studies, this
is a very problematic bill and we've continued
to see these problematic bills come out of
Texas. We'll. The ultimately where this lands